[Music]
it's it's hard to lump religion which
comes in many different forms shapes
sizes and and and viewed many ways by
different people in a single and a
single framework ultimately I think
religion is a net negative force for
Humanity because what it does at least
organized religion around the world is
it implies things about the real world
that are just not true that are that are
in disagreement with the evidence of
empirical testing and science and while
they may provide comfort to people
inevitably whenever you make decisions
based on something that's a myth the
decisions lead to bad consequences
whether you're teaching children or
subjugating women so religion of course
at various times in human history for
individuals provides comfort it has
provided opportunities for groups to
sometimes do progressive things but in
Nevitt ibly it's based on myth and
superstition based on ideas created by
rnh peasants who didn't even know the
earth orbited the Sun and ultimately why
we should view that as wisdom is beyond
me the saddest part that's
characteristic of everything including
the Quran and I don't want to label just
the Quran in this regard because I think
it's characteristic in the Old Testament
in the New Testament in the Abrahamic
religions is the xenophobia that that
that religion in truth is this us versus
them we are absolutely right because we
believe this or because we follow these
traditions and other people are
absolutely wrong because they don't and
then the question is what do you do to
the people who are wrong because they're
not part of your group well in many
cases you kill them or you ostracize
them or you send them to hell no one
mentions hell more than Jesus supposedly
he was a loving Savior but he meant he
uses the word hell more than anyone else
in the Bible so that's the same kind of
xenophobia in fact it's worse in my mind
as my late friend Christopher Hitchens
would say you know Saddam Hussein only
condemned his victims to violence and
death and you know until they died
what about a God who condemns you to
eternal pain forever but far worse than
a saddam hussein in the sky so i think
the kind of xenophobia the fact that
people who don't conform are to be
ostracized or killed is an is a is a
it's prevalent every religion and i can
understand it because these religions
were based in some sense of preserving
order within a tribe they're all
outgrowths of tribal behavior to
preserve order with the tribe it's
always us versus them here are rules
that define you as a Christian or a Jew
or a Muslim you do those rules and
you're welded you're distinguishable
from the other and the other is to be
swept away now in the current world
I think it's there's no doubt that right
now Islam is a source of more violence
than a number of the other organized
religions it's not the unique source of
violence but I think the the problem is
just one of timing its Islam is 500
years younger than then then say
Christianity and 500 years ago
Christianity was producing far more
violence than Islam ever is today from
the Crusades to the Inquisition and so
it's not surprising that a younger
religion is some sense is coming through
it's it's growing pains in that regard
the problem is we live in a time where
there's access to much more destructive
forces so you've got to worry a little
bit about that ultimately the real
problem
the real difference that I see between
Islam and and and say Judaism I mean the
Old Testament is every bit it's more
violent than the Koran it's more it's
full of violence oppression genocide
hatred it's an awful book and it's
amazing that we presented as a moral
standard for if you actually read the
Bible it's a disgusting disgusting
document there's there's beauty in the
Psalms and the poetry of the Psalms
perhaps but it's every bit as violent
if not more so than the current
the fundamental difference it seems to
me is that we've learned even highly
religious people take the take the the
the Bible allegorically says they take
it they don't when it says you can stone
your children if they disobey you no one
takes that seriously anymore the
difference is that people many people
take the Koran every word of the Koran
as as not only divine but literally and
therefore when it when it exerts you to
violence they take that literally that's
not done anymore in in in in the older
religions in the Abrahamic religions the
violent the the Bible still says to do
those awful things but people don't take
it seriously in fact when we talk about
religion in general many people call
themselves religious because if they
they think if they don't they're not
good people
there was a my friend Richard Dawkins
has his foundation in England did a poll
it looked after the most recent census
in England which happens to ask what
your religious affiliation is for the
first time only fifty three percent of
people are said they were Christians
about that number they took the people
who listed Christian in the box and said
do you believe in the virgin birth do
you believe in transubstantiation do you
believe in and the whole list of things
that are sort of standard parts of
Christianity most of those people said
no and then they were asked why did you
check the but check the the tick that
said you're Christian and the and they
said we like to think of ourselves as
good people and that's the what seems to
me the thing that we have to overcome
the most is people recognizing that you
can be a good person by accepting
reality for what it is and questioning
everything including questioning the
existence of God there's nothing wrong
with that I get letters from kids all
the time who say you know I'm happy to
see read your books or see your the
movie you've just done because it tells
me I'm not alone I'm not a bad person
for questioning what my elders or pastor
or teacher say in fact we
should be encouraging our children to
question everything it's part of
Education
[Music]